brooklyn-based photographer andre d
wagner has been documenting the lives of
everyday americans in his neighborhood
and city for nearly a decade now
so we asked wagner to reflect on this
current moment in america
in this original essay on being a black
photographer
after the police murdered george floyd
on camera i found myself struggling with
the weight of the moment
and what to do as a black photographer
only a month prior
i was walking in my brooklyn
neighborhood and the policemen took my
camera for a gun
something that i'm sure my black skin
played a role in
[Music]
so on the second day of protest i
decided to go to lower manhattan to
photograph and be part of the
demonstrations
as i made my journey from brooklyn to
manhattan i routinely stopped at the
elevated subway and looked down
what used to be a community garden is
now an empty lot sold to developers a
few years ago
i took a few photographs noticing two
construction workers
as i advanced to filming my camera i
glanced down
and one of the construction workers was
picking up an iron ride and points it
directly at me
like a gun and then proceeds with a
shooting motion
also directed at me laughing i paused
for what seemed like an eternity
and then continued up the stairs and
onto the subway
as i sat on the subway and traveled over
to williamsburg bridge
i found myself thinking the same thing
that other black boys and men like me
think in these situations
people will never believe us unless i
get it on camera
when i moved to new york from omaha in
2011 to pursue a masters in social work
i also discovered photography and the
work of another midwestern photographer
gordon parks i instantly felt a personal
kinship with what he wrote about his
camera
to him it was a weapon against racism
and poverty i've had a camera in my hand
ever since
[Music]
as a black man i see the world through
black eyes and it's this blackness that
shapes my perspective
because of the real world immediacy of
my medium being out in the world
photographing real people
my black body helps me see truthfully
i've learned to operate in my skin
doing my craft the way i do it in order
to survive
when i set out on these streets to make
photographs they can stand on their own
i know it's a tall order i don't have
the luxury to only deal with the medium
i know for a fact that my camera can be
mistaken for a gun i know that some
people will think that i'm doing
something suspicious
and i know that my wife worries about me
coming home safely
but i also know the pure joy of kids
playing in the streets
or the special bond share between the
father and daughter and i definitely
know the feeling of the young brother
lonely in the sea of faces on 34th
street
[Music]
after doing some more research i found
more information about the old community
garden
a black woman by the name of miss
hansley moved from north carolina
to new york in the 60s in search of a
better life
she landed in bushwick brooklyn and
founded what would be called the secret
garden
the same plot of land that these two men
stood on as they made a joke out of me
i used to think that being black would
be a burden as a photographer
i quickly changed my stance because now
my life in this gift of sight will be my
legacy
i became a black photographer in spite
of
i've had real moments of affirmation
looking through this viewfinder
nothing brings me more joy than to
organize the real world around me into
distinct moments
trying to get at the heart of anyone
willing to pause and look at my
photographs
it seems to me that one of the beautiful
aspects about art is that it places us
face to face with our history
in america we want to sweep our history
underneath the rug
but any real work of art won't let you